now the person trying to replace the
president potentially the last big-name
runner is about to enter the race for
the Democratic presidential nomination
sources tell CBS News former Vice
President Joe Biden will launch his
campaign tomorrow ahead of a fundraiser
in Philadelphia at O'Keefe is covering
the 2020 campaign at good morning good
morning John Biden's first formal
campaign event will be Monday in
Pittsburgh from there we're told he's
off to visit the early primary States
and plans to put special emphasis on
South Carolina a state where he enjoys
strong support from longtime Democratic
leaders this country can't afford more
years of a president looking to settle
personal scores we've got to get moving
former Vice President Biden will enter
the race for the 2020 Democratic
nomination in a place he's never been on
top the latest polling shows him leading
the large field of 2020 Democratic
hopefuls with 27 percent 7% ahead of
senator Bernie Sanders we will take back
this country I mean it don't give up
Biden's PAC sent an email to supporters
Tuesday hinting that an announcement is
coming soon though he's been toying with
the idea of getting into the race for
more than a year
with the holdup putting everything
together man admitting back in February
his family was on board while he wasn't
there yet they the most important people
in my life want me to run since then at
least eight women have alleged that
Biden made them feel uncomfortable in
the past actions for which he later
partially apologized I'm not sorry for
any of my intentions Biden has made a
run for president twice before I sat
down with him in late 2007 once
uncovered I'm convinced me matched
against Obama me matched against Hillary
me matched against anyone else I will do
just fine but Biden ended up placing
fifth in the Iowa caucus he dropped out
but later became Barack Obama's vice
president he chose not to run in 2016
after the death of his son Beau the year
before I regret it every day but I was
the right decision for my family and for
me at 76 Biden will be the second oldest
candidate in what's already a crowded
field and while he's popular with
working-class voters it's unclear if
he'll enjoy similar support from an
increasingly younger more liberal
democratic party less familiar with his
more than four decades of public service
Nora all right ed thank you